out of nowhere Bandai Namco and from
software have announced that a new type
of multiplayer is coming to Elden ring
in a free update the Coliseum update
which arrives tomorrow December 7th
invites players into the coliseums of
lim grave Lane Dell and Caleb where you
can fight in 1v1 duels as a part of a
team or in free for all matches all of
this comes to Elden ring in update 1.08
but the full patch notes haven't been
announced yet back in March several
modders found their way into the locked
coliseums and set off speculation about
what these locations were going to be
used for some of the guesses at the time
were challenges special boss fights and
a PVP Arena I have no plans to test my
skills in these coliseums but I have
been thinking a lot about Elden ring
lately for starters I never beat the
game and I've been craving that world
but another reason is because the game
awards are this Thursday and I'm more
than excited to watch it sweep the game
is nominated for game of the year as
well as six other Awards including best
game Direction and best narrative
something you won't see at this year's
game awards is the planned multiplayer
mode for cyberpunk 2077 and that's
because it has been officially canceled
in a new update from developer CD
projekt Red we've learned the online
mode became a casualty of the game's
turbulent release as the studio was
forced to focus all of its energy on
fixing the game's many issues what that
multiplayer game would have looked like
remains a mystery as CD projekt Red kept
details of the project tightly under
wraps and seldom spoke about it luckily
the game's Phantom Liberty expansion is
still on the way for PC PlayStation 5
and Xbox series X and sometime next year
as well as a sequel further into the
future and one update you won't have to
wait forever for is the latest from God
of War Ragnarok this update adds a very
popular feature for you virtual
photographers out there a photo mode the
mode lets players put facial expressions
on characters like Kratos atreus and
more as well as hide Main and Side
characters you can also change things
like field of view focal length depth of
field and f-stop in addition the photo
mode includes film grain and exposure
settings to Tinker with there is also
the ability to add borders logos and
vignettes to any photo and you should
probably jump into that photo mode and
get some great shots before the new DLC
for vampire survivors drops and takes
over your life that's right the hit
indie game that has kept me from
finishing recent releases from Pokemon
and God of War has announced Legacy of
the Moon spell this DLC will release on
December 15th and feature one really big
stage six new music tracks eight new
survivors 13 new weapons and a
mysterious amount of new monsters what
more could you ask for I mean other than
the game releasing you from his chains
of addiction comment which game you
can't stop playing and we'll see in the
next one
foreign